the Last of Us part two gets a violent
new trailer Robocop is coming to Mortal
Kombat 11 and cyberpunk 2077 is taking
character customization to the nether
regions I'm Curt and you've made it to
your safe state for Wednesday May 6
which is rated M for Mature
get ready for another white-knuckle
emotional rollercoaster because there's
a new story trailer for The Last of Us
part to the trailer gives a glimpse into
Joel & Ellie's father-daughter
relationship over the years and oh it
seems life has not been kind to Ellie
showing flashes of a traumatic event
that has left her scarred bruised and
bloodthirsty for revenge the game is
finally coming out to ps4 on June 19th
but Naughty Dog says there's still more
to show before then we're gonna do
standard whether or not the scheme
should get a sequel because I was
skeptical but holy hot this trailer is
good
[Music]
there's a cost
[Music]
we could have killed you maybe you
should have if the last of his trailer
wasn't violent enough
well Mortal Kombat's got an expansion on
the way and it's cold aftermath it adds
a new epilogue where Liu Kang tries to
create a new timeline there are also
three fighters joining in roster win got
Fujin half dragon Sheba and Robocop and
it's being voiced by the og actor
himself Peter Weller sure it's not
buckaroo banzai but uh I'll take it I
guess no matter where you go there you
are
who do you want to see Brian a Mortal
Kombat 11 next big bird or Kermit the
Frog anyways the DLC is coming out on
May 26 and we have a ton of preview
content on it so go to GameSpot to check
that ball out okay yeah cyberpunk 2077
is officially M for Mature no surprise
but what is a surprise is the options
for its character customization players
can select a gender and customize their
character customizations can include
depictions of breasts buttocks and
genitalia this is really immature
I'm so sorry players can select a gender
and customize their character
customization includes depiction of
breasts buttocks and genitalia as well
as various sizes and combinations of
genitals
unfortunately there's no detail on
whether that you'll be seeing something
other than Johnny's Silver Hand if
you're curious you can read the entire
ESRB content blurb on our website
GameSpot com
that's awesome now our movie news but
still game related the Borderlands movie
is wrapping up its cast Cate Blanchett
from Mrs America and Thor Ragnarok is in
the talks to play Lilith the movie will
be held by horror flick director and
Nazi killer Eli Roth Lilith has appeared
in Borderlands 1 2 & 3 she is more of a
mentoring role in Borderlands 3 so
perhaps Blanchett is playing this older
a version of her what's your dream boy
Lance cast let us know in the comments
below and that's it for Wednesday May 6
extremely violent safe states now
there's that and a whole lot more you
can read and learn about by going to
gamespot.com
also feel free to bug me whenever your
heart desires on twitter at curt
underscore in Davina alright see you at
tomorrow safe state and wash your hands
[Music]